question is was there any warning sign
that this was going to happen let's
let's pull pull the clips and like got
to Lake Como I've been dreaming about
getting to the specific hotel since I
saw it and like I walked in and Gregory
the like you know general manager was
there and he knew about everything but
like was playing it so cool had the most
amazing day like we both like looked at
each other and we were just like you
were like this is the most content I've
ever felt you started crying do you
remember that when we eat that Panini
emotional day for me that was a good
estimated how I get it it wasn't a
[__] a panini but it was so good
though